what is bitcoin
that's a question as complicated as what
is money
i think
if you get a general understanding of
money
from a number of angles
that we could say bitcoin is the most
superior
monetary technology that has ever
existed we think often in terms of goods
or services
but actually
everything is a service
so
it's not the physical properties of this
pen that i find valuable it's the
services that it renders to me that i
want to write a letter this gives this
serves me by allowing me to lay ink on
paper and communicate information
so
value humans attach value as we alluded
to earlier two services not goods
so the properties or the services that
money renders that human beings value
are those five properties divisibility
durability recognizability portability
scarcity
metals best satisfied those services
historically
but bitcoin as the most superior
monetary technology in human history
essentially perfects them
it's as close to perfection as we've
ever been so
in terms of divisibility each bitcoin
can be broken down into 100 million
subunits called a
satoshi um
it could if that divisibility were ever
a problem which actually um
there was a question that came up
recently if you divide the world
population
by the total supply of bitcoin you end
up at like 0.3 bitcoin per person call
it uh
300 000 satoshis per person
what if that was not enough to
facilitate economic activity
and the answer to that is bitcoin can
soft fork into further divisibility so
if bitcoin ate all the money in the
world
and the average
bitcoiner wealth would say 300 000
satoshi's each but that wasn't
uh divisible enough maybe to buy coffee
and do all these day-to-day transactions
what would happen well we would increase
divisibility so
bitcoin's perfected the visibility the
divisibility of money lets us transact
across scales right we can buy coffee or
we can buy a house
durability is an interesting one so
clearly something like gold is very
durable it's resistant to degradation
over time
bitcoin is just pure information but
it's stored in a distributed format
so
information stored in a distributed
fashion tends to be
virtually infinitely durable
the example i like to give here is
something like the bible
the bible is just distributed
information
it's stored everywhere and nowhere so to
speak
and for that reason it has outlasted
empires
and bitcoin's similar right you can't
make changes to it unilaterally
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn
everything you need to know about
bitcoin
enjoy
[Music]
rule number two change with the times
with rural paul give us your big picture
your big picture
40 000 feet looking down on the crypto
world what's your big picture to tell
everybody going forward
so as i've explained it's the fastest
growing adoption of any technology in
all recorded history we're going to go
from 150 million users to a billion
users in three and a half years
it is going from 2 trillion to 200
trillion as an asset class probably in
10 years
so this is the largest tailwind for any
investment we've ever been given
not only that
but it's creating an entirely new
business model for the world everything
is going to get tokenized from real
estate to stock markets to bond markets
to currency markets are all going to be
tokenized
on top of that people are using this to
build business models something called
web 3.0 which is where you you give a
community a system of money and say well
look you could all work together and
build your own network
there's decentralized finance there's
non-fungible tokens which allow you to
have
digital art and real art and real things
of value somebody's just got some aussie
wine there they've auctioned as an nft
so you get the rights to wine every year
from this nft
it's like okay this is interesting so
basically everything you buy sell own
store transfer
is going to be digitized
and this is that world
so if you can find me anything bigger
i don't know anybody you could this is
the very system of money and value
itself
and it's about to be disrupted by
technology
considering that the old system of money
has basically been around
for a few thousand years and we're about
to change it all that's how big this is
rule number three embrace bitcoin's
utilitarian aspect with michael saylor i
think it naturally follows
right digital energy digital property
digital money is the is the greatest
utilitarian
asset
they make greatest utilitarian value or
the greatest utilitarian asset on the
greatest utilitarian network
in the world in the history of the world
and
that means for 8 billion people
right it it offers
the possibility of economic empowerment
i think uh
if you want to give if you want to give
joy to eight billion people you need
digital music
and if you want to give education or
or enlightenment to 8 billion people you
need digital books or digital education
and if you want to give wealth to 8
billion people you need digital property
digital money
right
and um
[Music]
there is no other
uh there's nothing else that offers that
promise right
the reason bitcoin's powerful is because
at the end of the day you can put
trillions and trillions of dollars of
energy on the network and you can
distribute it over something like the
lightning network to eight billion
mobile devices and the mobile devices
cost fifty dollars
so the ability to give
uh economic energy to eight billion
people on a fifty dollar device
and do it with integrity and do it with
no
friction right like you're when you're
moving stuff with a lightning network
you're moving it for one satoshi
so it's friction free
speed of light
at any scale 37.37
000.37 million dollars
you know
at any frequency
right like i want to i want to vibrate
something right as tesla tesla's point
about understand frequency if i have a
billion dollars of gold i put it in a
vault the frequency is like once every
10 years
that's the velocity of the money
if i have a billion dollars and i put in
the fiat currency and move it over the
visa rails
and the fed wire
then it takes one to two months to move
it every time i if i make a charge
transaction before final settlement you
know it's gonna be 30 days before you
know that you're not going to get clawed
back in another 15 days or something so
so 45 to 60 days after i pay you for
something you can move it so you're
talking about velocity of six per year
annual velocity six per year
i put the same money on on the bitcoin
lightning network and the velocity is
six
per minute say
six per second six per hour right you're
talking about
uh a velocity which is orders of
magnitude higher and then of course the
cost is the visa network is two percent
two and a half percent friction
cost to move a billion dollars of
transactions
25 million dollars
the cost to move a billion on the
bitcoin network 68 cents
the cost to move that on the lightning
network if you break it into like
a hundred thousand transactions is get a
hundred thousand satoshi's
right so there's nothing comparable
right
it's a revolutionary transaction network
and it's also a revolutionary
uh monetary network both at the same
times like kind of dual revolutions
because you know in one in one case you
can
distribute economic energy
to billions and billions of people
billions of times an hour
and that is something of wonder
and in the other case you can store a
billion dollars of energy in a battery
for a hundred years
and still have the energy
and we don't have
any other
credit or cash
or asset instrument or property
instrument
where you could store a billion dollars
of economic energy for a hundred years
without dissipating it
and just a question of
how fast right in gold you dissipate 90
of it in 100 years
and
fiat like us dollars you dissipate 98
99 100 years
in electricity like
literal electrical energy you dissipate
100 no one can store that much
electrical energy for 100 years you just
paid it all it's all gone
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four become a market
observer with anthony pompliano when you
look at let's say bitcoin for example
i could talk to somebody all day long
and they can tell me bitcoin's not
valuable the best retort to that is
it's a trillion dollar asset that has
tens of millions of people around the
world holding it and it does more
transaction volume than some of the card
networks
sure maybe it's not valuable right but
like probably yeah but the market has
determined that that is valuable and you
just work your way through the assets
and what you find is asset after asset
that some group of people think is
invaluable well the market's decided it
has value now you could argue that the
market is wrong or mispricing it or
whatever and there's arbitrage
opportunities et cetera but ultimately i
think that um we're really bad at
predicting the future and so the more
that you can be a market observer rather
than a market predictor uh you start to
just understand uh crazy stuff happens
i'll give you a perfect example so i do
a lot of early stage investing right and
uh when i'm looking at early stage
opportunities there's two different
types of investors
some investors look at a business and
they say okay you want to build uh you
know a a company that built some kind of
widget
i think
that widget market is going to grow
bigger i think that you should do a b
and c i think right and they come at it
very much from
here is how i see this happening and
therefore i'm going to make my
investment decision on whether your
plans line up with how i think the world
is going to move in the future
that is a market predictor you're
predicating the investment decision on
the prediction of what you think is
going to happen in the future
and i did a lot of that early on some of
them work some did
over time what i became as a market
observer
is this person intelligent do they know
how to solve problems are they a clear
thinker do they think from first
principles
do they have traction in what they're
building regardless of whether i think
it's a thing or not right
there's a lot of people using it and so
what you start to do is you start to
become more of an observer and it it's
um it grounds you much more in like
humility from an investing standpoint of
saying i don't know what's gonna happen
in the future it could be bullish could
be bearish could be somewhere in between
but what i do want to see is i want to
see the trends things that are in motion
stay in motion and so if there's tons
and tons of users flocking to something
who cares what my opinion of the future
is right there's plenty of companies
that i think were really stupid
like imagine when somebody came in and
said hey uh we're gonna create a company
and we have air mattresses in our
kitchen and people are paying us to stay
there and we think everyone in the world
is gonna have an air mattress in their
kitchen
a lot of people are like that sounds
insane like that's never going to happen
because what are they doing they're
being a market predictor
but also along with that pitch was by
the way there was a conference this
weekend and at that conference we had
six people you know whatever pay for pay
us to do it and so people are doing it
if you're more from a market observer oh
that's interesting can did you do it
another weekend right the questions you
ask are different it's less about
where's the world going and it's more
about show me
that the
uh the observations that i have
available to me today that this is
working or that there's something here
rule number five be patient with anthony
scarmucci bitcoin historically has been
a pretty volatile asset obviously right
as someone who has dealt more with maybe
traditional equity markets or things
like that and manages billions of
dollars for clients how do you get
individual clients comfortable with that
volatility
um
well you have to size it appropriately
so that's one of my issues in my core
fund if i put a four percent position
and the and it grows to 20 percent
i have to probably scale it back so that
i can calm down my investors uh so what
i tell people if you're a bitcoin
maximus come into my bitcoin fund if
you're in my other fund let me size it
appropriately because it will be
volatile
but you guys know this and i think
there's some historical perspective
necessary to share here
all these
medcap law
network effect investments
they start out in the early adoption
phase with mega volatility why
you've got all the fuddy-duddies and the
ancients shorting it disbelieving it
shorting tesla shorting amazon
amazon's going to miss its number it's
1999. let me short the goddamn thing
and
they
create the volatility same thing happens
in bitcoin you know we hit an air pocket
with elon musk in china bitcoin's at 65
000. it's at 29 000. i've got clients
lighting me up
and you guys know this everybody's a
long-term investor until they have
short-term losses when they have
short-term losses they set their hair on
fire they run around in a circle and so
i my one of my jobs is to be the
financial
and psychological coach i've got to tell
people calm down
stay the course we have a five-year plan
or a three-year plan
and i'll just point out because i think
it's worth mentioning if you were an
early investor in amazon uh you know
just think about this for a second the
ipo of amazon may 15 1997.
a ten 10 000 investment is now worth 21
million dollars 21 million 140 000
however you would have had to subject
yourself to eight periods of time where
it dropped at least 50 percent
one period of time where it went down 85
and the barons newspaper had a front
page article amazon.bomb
the age of this internet retailer is
over
but the cat that made amazon jeff bezos
he shot himself into space in his own
rocket
okay so what do you guys want to do do
you want to
be patient
and look at something like bitcoin and
see the exponential growth of wallets
and the scale and understand the value
of the network effect of those
properties associated there with and
stay patient
and watch bitcoin eclipse gold in terms
of its market capitalization
or do you want to trade it and get juked
out of it at the wrong moment and do
what
non-psychologically minded investors do
is they sell lows and they buy highs
and so to me i got to get in the face i
got to get in i have to grab the face
mask of my clients and pull them close
to me like a good coach and say stop it
get your emotions out of this thing
this is a revolutionary asset this is
digital
waterfront property this is digital
energy that is going to transform the
world and over the blockchain we are
going to de-layer
our society we're going to take
third-party
intermediaries out of the society it'll
be a cost savings it'll be ecologically
friendly
there'll be quantum benefits associated
with this and you can own a piece of
this property today
at a very attractive price this is you
and me pomp going to miami beach in 1921
and buying oceanfront property rule
number six look at bitcoin as property
with kevin o'leary when i talk to
institutions there's a change in
philosophy about their thinking let's
just stay with bitcoin bitcoin used to
be considered for many institutions that
hadn't owned it yet the ones that were
just looking at it as a currency
they're not thinking that way anymore
they're looking at it as a property
so you would buy it in the same way as a
aaa office tower in manhattan you buy an
allocation to coin that you're allowed
to own you never trade it you own it as
an asset you know it's compliant it
checks the box
you own it on your balance sheet your
providence and it's something that you
can own as property and that's where i
think we're going some percentage will
still be traded
but for the big institutions coming in
this is an asset class that is a
property and rule number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is use bitcoin as collateral with mark
cuban just for bitcoin if it's just
digital gold well does that really match
up with the original promise well you
know i'm not i didn't read the white
paper i couldn't tell you all the
details of the original prom list and i
don't really care um what i know is what
i know right now and in you know the
existing environment you could use it as
collateral
and when you can use it as collateral
and you can swap it and where depending
on where you swap it you can do it
efficiently and effectively then your
options expand and so because it's um
it's got a liquid marketplace you can
assign a value to it not just as a store
of value but to act as collateral for
other transactions and what's happening
is with d5 you know doing financial
transactions the friction is far less
than it is in traditional
centralized analog
finance
i happen to have a reasonable amount of
belief
that over time it's going to continue
going up because of what i mentioned
before humans have forever been looking
for a store of value that allows money
to maintain its purchasing power over
space and time
and bitcoin by narrative as i understand
it seems to be the most effective at
storing value over space and time
because it's digital it has a hard cap
there will never be more of it and its
adoption is ridiculously fast now
the only thing the only technology ever
that shows an even faster adoption curve
than bitcoin
is ethereum now ethereum hasn't been
around as long so who knows again maybe
it goes to zero
and that notion of there's only one gold
so there's probably only going to be one
digital gold
that's why i'm more bullish on
bitcoin than i am on ethereum but in
full disclosure my portfolio is
uh in terms of value
is almost 50 50.
even though as of today i've put in
about half the money into ethereum that
i have into bitcoin so with half of the
input
i've gotten
the same amount of value
in ethereum that i did in bitcoin
now this could this changes day by day
so who knows what that's going to be
tomorrow who knows what it's going to be
in a year from now i have no idea
so but that's the way i think about it
so bitcoin you've got as gold and then
the way that people refer to ethereum is
the if bitcoin is digital gold then
ethereum is digital oil
and they literally call the fees on
ethereum gas fees
so that's like if you think about one is
used constantly and the other is a store
of value that's a good way to think
about now if i'm honest in my daily life
the way that i think about ethereum is
as money because i spend it constantly
so i'm buying it not just to have a
store of value i'm buying it so that i
can
buy nfts that i can be engaged in that
community and other goods that will pop
up over time
that you're able to purchase with
ethereum right now the big ones are to
lock your money up in d5 which is like
putting in a bank account and earning
interest
and i know precious little about d5 so
take that with a grain of salt
and then
in
nfts
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the master class crypto
investing compilation we put together
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i buy uh a
million dollars of gold
okay um
if the price goes up the gold miners
first of all the gold miner is going to
create more gold and dump it on the
market